all right we're gonna start somewhere
else though this morning beachgoers are
being urged to stay vigilant this summer
amid an alarming number of injuries and
even deaths caused by drivers on the
beach here's the background a series of
recent accidents is forcing some Florida
communities to reconsider the
long-standing tradition of allowing
vehicles on some beaches Kris Van Cleave
went there to see how dangerous the
situation has become good morning at
least 12 states allow you to drive on at
least some beaches and it's kind of fun
you can see why it's a big tourist draw
and for locals can be a time-honored
tradition but at least three accidents
this year here on Amelia Island it's
raising questions about the safety of
cars and people sharing the sands
security camera video captures the
moment this Jeep Grand Cherokee drove
over a sand dune and hit a Sun bather on
Amelia Island Florida in May and she's
not the only one I just got ran over my
legs just got ran over by a white Jeep
that's pulling out right now just weeks
earlier Amanda gonzales was laying a
mile up the same beach when she too was
run over by a different Jeep I felt a
lot of pain I set up and I come nose to
tire with the Jeep did a driver stopped
to see if you were okay
no I don't know if they know they were
in me over I I don't know if they saw me
the mother of two is still recovering
from injuries to her legs and back she
can't drive and has been unable to work
since the April crash Gonzales wants
vehicles off the beach every time I
close my eyes I saw tires coming up my
head and
it still happens and it's hard third
vehicle driving at night ran over a
well-marked endangered sea turtle nest
like this one Nassau County home to
Amelia Island charges $5 a day for
visitors to take a vehicle on the beach
technically the law allows drivers to
park there but videos show potentially
dangerous behavior like cars doing
donuts it's preposterous lawyer John
Phillips has represented six women in
the last seven years who are run over
while sunbathing on Florida beaches
he says he's identified more than 40
other incidents in Florida alone letting
pedestrian vehicles on a beach seems to
be driven by almost antiquated your and
I'm making their grandfather's drove on
the beach so they're gonna drive on a
beach at least a dozen states allow some
form of beach driving and while deaths
are uncommon they have happened and
accidents are not well tracked
unlike injury or deadly crashes on the
road beach accidents are not reported
nationally we don't know for certain how
many events and how many injuries how
many deaths occur and anytime there's a
combination of motor vehicles and
pedestrians in a relatively unprotected
environment and a very chaotic
environment the risk is really elevated
the city of Fernandina Beach tightened
its beach regulations and police now
encourage sunbathers not to lay in the
area open to vehicles local officials
are weighing whether to make the beaches
car free but that's controversial with
residents and tourists like Linda Barry
and her daughter who drove ours
specifically to park on this stretch of
sand straight to the beach and she had
never drove on the beach so yeah that
was nice there are no easy answers Mayor
Johnny Miller is hoping for some middle
ground we can figure out a way to get
along to make it symbiotic that we can
have people and cars you know the access
the beach cars and people continue to
share the beach here in Amelia Island as
both the county and city really struggle
with what to do to try to make the
practice safer bottom line it's
tradition first safety
for CBS this morning Kris Van Cleave
Amelia Island Florida safety should win
I think we figured it out at the table
jury not a good idea I think you should
be able to have an air where you can
park your vehicle right but why would
you want to keep driving up and down the
coastline I love the idea each goers
stay vigilant if I'm going to the beach
I'm not that's not the idea relaxed area
are the cars an area for the Sunday
they're not so hard
I don't know safety should always win I
think